13 1716 fälle 2538 mehr als am vortag
die vereinigten staaten haben wir eine
offizielle meldezahl von 9000 40 15 das
sind fast 3000 mehr als am vortag also
sie sehen dass diese pandemie weiter
läuft und es wird in allen ländern zur
erhöhung der zahl in den nächsten wochen
kommen
es ist eine dynamische entwicklung und
sie zeigt eben leider in fast allen
ländern nach oben so wie das auch in
deutschland der fall ist
und jetzt kommen wir zu deutschland die
situation ein wenig genauer in den blick
genommen die zahlen die ihn jetzt von
der melde- sind die wir angekündigt
haben
das sind immer die zahlen von null uhr
also von 20 30 uhr
in deutschland wurden bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt rund 14.000 fälle elektronisch
übermitteln 13 1957 ganz genau und das
sind gegenüber dem vortag mit 2009 158
fälle mehr
ich sagte dass bereits wir sind in einem
exponentiellen wachstum bei uns wohnen
insgesamt 31 todesfälle übermittelt
bislang sind elf mehr als am vortag
schon heute schnell also bei uns wurden
2009 158 übermittelte fälle mehr als am
vortag
und insgesamt haben wir 31 todesfälle
bis heute 0 uhr übermittelt bekommen und
das sind 11 mehr als es am vortag uns
übermittelt wurden ein wenig genauer
hineingeschaut in die zahlen die uns
offiziell übermittelt worden
wir haben in deutschland eine gesamt
incident inzwischen schon von 17 fällen
pro 100.000 ich sage es nochmal das ist
ein exponentielles wachstum aber diese
evident diese inzidenz variiert
deutschlandweit stark auch das betone
ich immer wieder das ist ein grund warum
man in verschiedenen regionen auch
unterschiedlich starke maßnahmen fahren
kann angepasst in analysen
wir müssen immer mit kühl
kopf alle uns zur verfügung stehenden
daten analysieren und entsprechend
handeln in hamburg zum beispiel haben
wir 32 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner in
türen sieben fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
was sind die symptome der fälle in
deutschland stand 20.30 uhr
wir wissen von 9000 fällen rund welche
klinischen informationen vorliegen sehr
viele haben husten mehr als die hälfte
haben husten trockener husten ist ein
typisches symptom was wir immer mehr
lernen und was ich immer mehr bestätigt
fieber haben 40 prozent der gemeldeten
fälle also jeder fürchte vier von zehn
hat diese diese symptome in deutschland
differieren die zahlen von bundesland zu
bundesland sehr stark baden württemberg
hatten wir um 0 uhr 2007 146 fälle in
bayern
2401 in nordrhein-westfalen 3497 in
anderen bundesländern kann das ganz
anders aussehen thüringen 149 und
mecklenburg vorpommern 131 also
unterschiedliche zahlen wie bei jeder
epidemie verlaufen diese epidemien
regional unterschiedlich und das ist
auch wichtig zu verstehen so dass auch
die maßnahmen die die landräte und
landrätinnen von die oberbürgermeisterin
und oberbürgermeister die dafür
verantwortlich sind wie vor ort reagiert
wird was sie auch dazu veranlassen kann
unterschiedlich gratulierte maßnahmen
anzuordnen
meine damen und herren wir sind
natürlich inzwischen auch in der
überlegung ob es zukunft noch so sein
wird dass wir risikogebiete auswerten
das werden wir schauen wir haben immer
davon gesprochen dass sich in einer
dynamischen lage unsere kriterien
ständig überdacht werden angepasst
werden wir werden das sehen
wie wir damit weiter umgehen es kann
sein dass in manchen regionen nicht mehr
sinnvoll ist es getrennt zu betrachten
für uns sind die risikogebiete immer
definiert worden um ärzten eine
handlungsanweisung zu geben eine
empfehlung zu geben warum sie eine
person testen müssen oder nicht es sind
epidemiologische mark systematischer
marca systematisch indikatoren für ärzte
und ärztinnen um personen zu testen oder
nicht
und zu wissen ob person zu bestimmten
risikogebieten gehören
wir schauen dann wenn demnächst überall
risikogebiete sind ob wir das noch
weiter tragen können ein paar
informationen noch weiter ich hatte ein
dashboard angekündigt sodass viele
genauere informationen haben können über
die dynamik bilder sind sehr wichtig
vermittler unter anderem ihr das
geschehen sehr viel leichter als zahlen
ich glaube das geht den meisten menschen
so das dashboard ist jetzt online
geschaltet ab 8 uhr heute morgen dort
können sie auf landkreisebene sehen die
anzahl der fälle das sind gute grafiken
verständlichen grafiken wir arbeiten da
zusammen mit der firma es wie in
deutschland
und auch andere ressort
forschungsinstitute unterstützen uns
hier großartig mit kartenmaterial das
wird also kontinuierlich
auch das wird kontinuierlich weiter
bearbeitet auch hier sind wir natürlich
in einem dynamischen prozess und wir tun
soviel wie möglich um unsere bevölkerung
so gut wie möglich so transparent wie
möglich zu informieren das ist ganz
wichtig dass jeder der weiß was
geschieht in unserem land da käme auch
neue informationen dazu zum beispiel die
zahl der neuinfektionen pro tag oder der
anstieg der fallzahlen über einen
bestimmten zeitraum
wir werden also dieses tool immer
weiterentwickeln um allen die
gelegenheit zu geben einblicke zu haben
in das was in unserem land geschieht das
wird täglich zu einem situationsbericht
ergänzend seien
auch hier nochmal der hinweis dass das
dashboard auf offiziellen meldedaten
beruht also den fällen die von den
gesundheitsämtern elektronisch an das
rki übermittelt hören wir werden
versuchen dieses dashboard jeden tag um
0 uhr abzudecken genauso zu der zeit wo
wir die zahlen die ich ihnen verkünde
morgens oder mein kollege professor
schade dass nämlich zum schluss noch mal
ein appell richten an alle und ich sag
das noch mal ganz ganz ernsthaft bewusst
mit aller entschiedenheit
wir können diese epidemie nur
verlangsamt wenn wir uns an die
spielregeln halten distanzierung abstand
halten
das virus wird in erster linie von
mensch zu mensch übertragen jeder muss
verstehen dass ja mindestens ein meter
fünfzig zwei meter abstand halten soll
damit er keinen anderen ansteckt wer
krank ist bleibe bitte zu hause und wenn
er zu hause bleibt bleibe er bitte auch
so weit wie möglich distanziert er sich
eben von seinen mit familienmitgliedern
um sie nicht anzustecken
das virus wird von mensch zu mensch
übertragen wir alle können die
übertragung dadurch verlangsamen oder
einstellen das heißt bitte halten sie
abstand und wenn es menschen gibt die
auf einen test warten und das ergebnis
vielleicht nicht umgehend bekommen bitte
nehmen sie sich in selbst quarantäne
bleiben sie bitte zu hause
das muss jeder verstehen und ich
wiederhole auch noch mal ein appell auch
das sagen wir seit anfang dieser
epidemie
jeder kann von diesem virus infiziert
werden unabhängig von der altersgruppe
aber das risiko schwer zu erkranken und
verstärkt zu versterben steigt mit dem
alter und den grundkrankheiten dh auch
wenn junge menschen nur leichte symptome
haben können sie aber trotzdem alte
menschen anstecken und dann dazu
beitragen dass die alten menschen sich
infizieren bitte nehmen sie rücksicht
wir alle können eben auch andere
schützen
und ich denke das wollen wir auch alle
mit allen menschen mit denen ich bisher
gesprochen habe alle die verstanden
haben was diese epidemie für unser land
bedeutet die verstehen das und ich sehe
unheimlich viele gute auswirkungen ganz
viele beispiele wo menschen das
verstehen und ich bitte sie hier eben
auch im hörsaal diese distanzen zu
wahren und wir überlegen uns wie wir das
hier auch demnächst noch anders
regulieren wir werden sehen ob wir das
in der fall war
in der art und weise wie wir das
pressebriefing machen dass in der
zukunft machen
es gibt eine untersuchung von bitkom
einem digital verband eine
repräsentative umfrage und der zufolge
sind viele menschen hierzulande immer
noch nicht bereit ihre sozialen kontakte
zu reduzieren trotz aller appelle von
mir von vielen anderen leuten die
verantwortungsbewusst den deal
sicherheit und die gesundheit unserer
mitmenschen wirklich ein großes anliegen
ist nur jeder zweite der befragten geht
kommen auf die straße oder trifft sich
seltener mit freunden und familie
jeder vierte meint das alles für
panikmache
ich habe diesen job hier angetreten weil
ich gesagt habe unser robert koch
institut möchte bürger schützen möchte
die gesundheit der bürger verbessern
möchte dazu beitragen wissenschaftlich
fundierte ergebnisse in die bürger
einbringen in alle menschen in
deutschland leben und das ist mein
auftrag das ist er seit nunmehr fünf
jahren und 20 tagen und alle im
robert-koch-institut tun das ihrige dazu
ohne diesen dieser arbeit zu erleichtern
die informationen die ich ihnen
vermitteln sind nicht meine information
eines experten der sich täglich
weiterbildet und beliebt sondern es sind
die informationen die mir ein team von
mehreren hundert kolleginnen und
kollegen aus dem institut gibt
informationen die wir erhalten von
befreundeten wissenschaftlern
wissenschaftlerinnen
aus anderen instituten wie wir sie sind
es gibt fast jedem land institute wie
das robert-koch-institut mit
verschiedenen ausrichten sind
informationen die wir erhalten in
beratungen mit gruppen der whu ich
selber bin mitglied einer beratergruppe
der wow beraten direkt mike ryan den
chef des wird im murger des programms
ein mann den ich bereits will ich schon
bereits mehrfach gesagt habe extrem
bewundere der seit jahrzehnten sich mit
allen krisen rumschlägt erfahrene leute
ich sage ihnen das weil ich überzeugt
bin davon das ist richtig ist und im
nachhinein werdet auch das ein oder
andere vielleicht hätte man lieber
anders gesagt oder früher oder später
wir alle sind in einer krise die ein
ausmass hat dass ich mir selber nie
hätte vorstellen können und wir tun alle
so gut wie möglich dass wir diese krise
so gut wie möglich meistern
darum noch mal zum schluss wir brauchen
in den hospitälern so viel wie möglich
beatmungs betten wir brauchen so viel
wie möglich intensivbetten ich
appelliere seit wochen an die
krankenhäuser sich darauf vorzubereiten
auf diese krise aber jetzt muss es so
weit sein
ja ich erwarte jetzt dass die
krankenhäuser vorbereitet sind
denn die die fälle werden zunehmen und
ich sage es auch nochmal ganz viele
menschen werden diese krankheit ganz
easy überstehen
wir haben jetzt schon sicher mehr als
1000 menschen die die krankheit
überstanden von denen wir wissen es
werden wahrscheinlich mehr sein aber es
werden eben auch sehr viele sehr shorten
schwer erkranken und die müssen wir
schützen
um die geht es dass wir sie medizinisch
noch adäquat versorgen können darum
bitte halten sie abstand wenn sie krank
sind bleiben sie zu hause
stecken sie niemanden an halten sie
abstand und dann werden wir das so gut
wie möglich hinbekommen dass wir so
viele wie möglich unsere mitmenschen die
in unserem land leben
medizinisch gut betreuen danke sehr ihre
fragen
also die antwort ist die die ich schon
lange gebe und die korrekt ist wir
stehen am anfang einer epidemie wenn
eine epidemie serie also eine kurve
vorstellen da sind wir links unten noch
wir rutschen aber immer weiter nach oben
ja wir haben es früh erkannt weil wir
früh getestet haben und wir werden
leider in zukunft mehr fälle haben bei
uns gilt als kronach todesfall jemand
der bei dem eine corona virus infektion
nachgewiesen wurde
das kann ich nicht so detailliert
beantworten aber von dem was wir sehen
denken wir dass die jüngeren sich am
unvernünftig sind verhalten also eben
immer noch zu stark zusammen kommen wir
haben aber nicht genügend daten wir
finden die mehrheit der infizierten die
getestet werden sind mit leute in der
mittelalten gruppe zwischen 30 und 50
wir können das noch nicht so detailliert
sagen aber ich will nur noch mal sagen
jeder muss sich distanzieren muss
möglichst sich von anderen verein halten
um keine anderen anzustecken und wer
weitergehende maßnahmen insgesamt
meine rolle ist die eines
wissenschaftlers eines unabhängigen
wissenschaftler dass diese institute hat
ja mehrere vorteile wie es stehen nicht
in einem wettbewerb wie das vielleicht
andere wissenschaftler tun um bestimmte
drittmittel und bestimmte incentives wir
stehen nicht in einem wettbewerb mit
kommerziellen anbietern wir sind
unabhängig das ist die große stärke und
das ist der grund warum so ein laden wir
unsere überhaupt gibt also schulden sie
das also ein institut wie unseres
überhaupt gibt das heißt wir können
nichts weiter tun als die fakten und die
annahmen die wir berechnen zu vermitteln
was wir empfehlen habe ich gesagt
maximale distanzierung abstand halten
die maßnahmen die sich daraus ergeben
müssen die verantwortungsträger
natürlich ableiten wir empfehlen wir
sind wissenschaftler
das ist unser job und auf den
empfehlungen die wir von unserem
wissenschaftlichen knowhow hergeben
müssen maßnahmen von den
entscheidungsträgern umgesetzt werden
das ist nicht unser job die freunde
sagen sie bitte noch in welchem medium
sich im tank gesprochen
die kapazität von 160.000 prof wir sind
sie wie viele tatsächliche tests
stattfinden und wie sich das verändert
und ist eine frage gibt es vom lka
schutz also die die zahlen steigen
eigentlich immer weiter die test
kapazitäten werden immer weiter
hochgefahren
ich kann ihnen die die den umfang nicht
genau nennen ja aber es werden im
prinzip immer mehr
das war sie ihn sagt 160.000 war die
durchgeführten tests ja klar gibt es
schutz angaben ich meine es gibt die
klaren empfehlungen
die gab es ja auch schon vor der korona
krise das corona virus ist ein virus das
über tröpfchen übertragen wird
und dafür gibt es ganz normale
anweisungen wie man sich schützt im
krankenhaus ja da gibt es empfehlungen
von der kripo und von verschiedenen
gruppierungen die sind die haben sich
nicht verändert
all das für alle also für alle diese
bereiche wo sind die versorgung von
medien von patienten gibt und auch in
alten- pflege- und altenheim gibt es
empfehlungen von uns selbstverständlich
und die sind klar
das sind nämlich das tragen von
schutzkleidung und schutzmasken und mund
nasen schutz
aus gesprächen mit vielen menschen
wirklich den eindruck viele verstehen
mit normaler
ja also warum die menschen vor grippe
nicht so viel sorge haben wie sie haben
sollten ist mini eingängig gewesen ich
bitte sie alle die die bio berichten
auch klar zu machen dass crippen
schwerwiegende krankheit ist aber
unabhängig davon
diese krankheit überträgt sich sehr
effizient ja leichter
das heißt also die übertragung von einem
menschen zum anderen ist gelingt
leichter als bei der gruppe der anteil
der menschen die schwer erkranken ist
deutlich höher der anteil der menschen
in den risikogruppen die so schwer
erkranken dass die beratungspflicht ich
werden ist deutlich höher
und der anteil der menschen die an
dieser krankheit sterben in den
risikogruppen ist deutlich höher
ich glaube es gibt nichts was ist klar
um art dass wir hier eine größere
problematik haben wir haben auch in
unsere risikoeinschätzung darüber habe
ich auch letztens berichtet wir
analysieren ja viele systeme wir haben
vier systeme in deutschland mit denen
wir den krankheits schwer und grad die
sogenannte burden of disease berechnen
und wir wissen dass insgesamt diese
krankheit auch nach unseren analysen
einfach eine schwere krankheitslast
macht und einfach viel mehr menschen
infiziert werden und viel mehr menschen
in die notaufnahmen bekommen werden und
viel mehr menschen beatmet werden müssen
und deshalb müssen wir befürchten dass
die arbeitsplätze nicht reichen
diese krankheit ist schwerer und wird
mehr menschen betreffen wenn das immer
noch menschen im saarland gibt die das
nicht glauben
oder die mir nicht glauben oder die das
für panikmache halten dann kann ich nur
noch meinem wissen nach bestem wissen
und gewissen und meiner kenntnis kann
ich sie nur auffordern endlich die augen
zu öffnen vor dieser realität
habe ich hier auch dann später wieder
zurückkommen und das ihrer meinung nach
wir müssen ich sage es nochmal wenn wir
uns alle daran halten das was vorgegeben
wird
dann können wir diesen ausbruch der
epidemie maximal verlangsamen
und es mag sein dass es bestimmte
regionen gibt in denen bestimmte
zustände sind wo man noch weiter denken
kann ich sage es nochmal das liegt ja in
dem ermessen der entscheidungsträger vor
ort wir müssen das analysieren wir tun
das so gut wir können wir haben viele
informationen um zu wissen wie in
bestimmten regionen deutschlands
bestimmte verbreitungswege sind und das
müssen leute entscheiden die unsere
daten entsprechend kennen
zur situation zur situation in den
krankenhäusern sie haben wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe gerade gesagt
dass relativ oder des patienten in
krankenhäusern gibt die lediglich husten
als symptom haben habe ich das richtig
verstanden und wäre das ab wann ist es
empfehlenswert den weg zum krankenhaus
zu gehen und nicht zu hause zu bleiben
spätestens wenn sie atemnot bekommen ja
atemnot bekommen das heißt also wenn sie
merken dass sie die die dass sie
wirklich schlecht luft bekommen dann
spätestens ist natürlich der zeitpunkt
gekommen wo sie sich an einen arzt
wenden beziehungsweise auch notfalls ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert werden
ich glaube nicht dass ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass menschen im krankenhaus
sind weil sie husten
der der kollege der kollege war vorne
entschuldigung entschuldigung
entschuldigung der kollege
ich weiß ich weiß wir versuchen alle der
reihe nach dran zu nehmen und bitte alle
halten sich daran dass werden heute
nicht alle dran kommen können nein tue
ich nicht ich ignoriere den haben hier
vorne in ihn also eins nach dem anderen
ich bitte um verständnis bitten sie mit
dem buch
ich merke gerade dass die zuschauer die
fragen ja gar nicht mehr mitbekommen
sie haben alle kein mikro in der hand
also es geht um die daten der telekom
ich kann hier noch keine auswertung dazu
geben aber ich möchte noch mal folgendes
sagen die sind aggregierten daten keine
personen persönlichen daten anonymisiert
und aggregierte daten sie uns einfach
zeigen ob die bewegungs ob die menschen
in deutschland sich wirklich weniger
bewegen um abschätzen zu können wie die
maßnahmen die geforderten auch umgesetzt
zu werden und dann können wir sehen
inwiefern das dann auch mit einer
rückkehr der erwünschten rückgang der
infektionen koalieren so wird sagen drei
fragen schaffen wir noch ganz schnell
geht zunächst sie hat sich auch schon
länger gemeldet mich interessiert vor
allem nehmen wir mal an die also das ist
jetzt so hoffen die fallzahlen werden
gebremst
die massnahmen abstand halten etc haben
erfolg aber heißt das nicht dass diese
dann sehr lange in kraft bleiben müssen
weil wenn man die wieder lockert wenn
die zahlen ja sofort wieder hoch gehen
wir müssen das immer beobachten und wir
müssen die maßnahmen entsprechend
anpassen das ist keine frage wir werden
jetzt erst mal schauen vielleicht die
nächsten zwei wochen werden wir sehen
wie sich das entwickelt und ich kannte
mal sagen ist eine dynamische situation
wo man regelmäßig immer angepasst
reagieren muss aber niemand weiß wie
sich das entwickelt darum analysieren
was so etwas können und daran wenn dann
die maßnahmen sicher angepasst
bestimmte dienste
sie hatten letzte woche gesagt man könne
die pandemie oder die wenigen noch
verlangsamen nicht mehr eindämmen
die deutschen gesellschaften die melodie
hat gestern gesagt man könne noch eine
frage entscheidung präsident hätte
unsere strategie für hochgefährlich
bedingungen nennt man nur ein bisschen
überlegt über den infizierten zeit
bricht das gesundheitssystem zusammen
sie haben nach dem pokal jetzt endlich
in dem zusammenhang auf die frage der
vorstoß von der stadt innsbruck geld die
ärztegewerkschaft beantworten hat sich
gestern für eine herten immunität als
ziel ausgesprochen obwohl die bh um ganz
klar sagt dass das fiz riskant ist auch
überall anders möchte machen möchte was
sagen sie dazu
und zur verhältnismäßigkeit
geschäftsschließungen es sind
hunderttausende unternehmer
wahrscheinlich vor dem ruin
wer sich für die wehren einen masten
pflicht in der öffentlichkeit ganz
worden wie tschechien das getan haben
und wie harry potters für die supermarkt
ich arbeite jetzt wie er sagt folie
ehemaliger mitarbeiter ihren ärger seit
wochen empfiehlt die deutsche
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene sagt
auch jede maske schützt besser als keine
masse also ich sage es nochmal wir
werden wir werden hinterher wissen was
die besten maßnahmen waren die maßnahmen
die wir empfehlen sind nach bestem
wissen und gewissen gemacht die die idee
einer herdenimmunität halten wir für
sehr sehr schwierig weil dieses virus
sich sehr leicht überträgt und wir
müssen alles dafür tun dass wir die
krankheitsfälle so stark wie möglich
reduzieren
wir wissen nach dem heutigen stand das
masken tragen
vor allen dingen die anderen schützt
also die menschen die selber infiziert
sind
das wissen wir das sagen wir auch schon
seit langer zeit die menschen die sehr
bei infiziert sind schützen andere vor
der infektion und das ist auch wichtig
dass diese menschenmassen kann für die
im gesundheitssystem das muss uns auch
allen klar sein
diejenigen die im krankenhaus arbeiten
und die in den pflegediensten und worden
aber das sind natürlich die menschen die
wir am meisten schützen müssen weil sie
natürlich mit infizierten das größte
risiko haben mit infizierten menschen
zusammenzukommen und wir lernen alle in
dieser krise wir tauschen uns ständig
aus und wir hoffen dass wir die besten
rezepte haben dass wenn wir im
nachhinein tut mir leid für alle anderen
damals in der geschäfts 2017 ab und das
25.000 menschen an der grippe gestorben
sind und die menschen dann glaube ich
damals aber kaum von diesem geschehen
mitbekommen auch die in den
krankenhäusern wie war damals die
maßnahmen zur eindämmung und hätten
vielleicht solche ja sehr weitgehenden
maßnahmen die heute damals zum sprechen
vielleicht auch hätte geben können und
hätten die auch vielleicht verhindern
können also die damalige grippe war eine
sehr schwere grippe und damals war das
gesundheitssystem schon sehr sehr sehr
gestresst also damals schon waren in den
krankenhäusern die intensivbetten sehr
stark besetzt und das dass das system
war sicher damals schon gestresst
das haben wir auch sehr viele
wahrgenommen also auch während der zeit
darauf da wurde sehr viel darüber
berichtet und das ist ganz klar
keine frage dass wir uns vor grippe
besser schützen sollten aber ich möchte
es noch mal klar sagen wir haben einen
impfstoff
ja also warum lassen sich die menschen
in deutschland die risikogruppen den wir
das jedes jahr empfehlen warum lassen
sich in deutschland nur 30 prozent der
über 60-jährigen impfen
das ist eher ein entscheidender
unterschied wir haben eher werkzeuge das
ist ja auch ein punkt den wir immer
wieder betont
was ist sind die drei großen oder die
vier großen unterschiede zwischen grippe
und dem saas corona virus zur ersten
grippe gibt es einen impfstoff der allen
risikogruppen kostenfrei zur verfügung
gestellt werden weil saß corona gibt es
momentan keinen impfstoff grippe gibt es
medikamente die ebenfalls verschrieben
werden können und im frühen zeit meiner
krankheit helfen
aktuell stand heute gibt es gegen lars
corona virus zwei keine medikamente
drittens kinder spielen bei influenza
bei der übertragung von influenza eine
große rolle bei saas corona ist es so
dass nach heutigem stand des wissens
alle altersgruppen die infiziert werden
gleiches risiko für andere darstellen
sie anzustecken und der fürther
unterschied und den hatte ich gerade
noch mal erläutert die krankheitslast
ist deutlich größer das heißt die anzahl
der menschen die schwer krank werden in
risiko ist deutlich größer die
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit die
übertragbarkeit ist ist höher und die
anzahl derjenigen die eine krankheit
versterben es höher wir haben also eine
ganz andere dimension
ja das sind ganz entscheidende
unterschiede und auch ich wäre froh wenn
die menschen sich einfach mehr gegen
grippe schützen würden und auch da
natürlich darauf achten dass sie andere
mitmenschen nicht anstecken das gilt für
jeden das sagen wir auch jedes jahr und
das werden wir auch im nächsten jahr
sagen und wir werden jedes jahr wieder
alle menschen auffordern sich impfen zu
lassen und ich hoffe dass wir dann
irgendwann im jahr 20 21 möglichst früh
einen impfstoff haben und dass ich dann
auch die menschen auffordern kann und
wir alle dass ich gegen korona impfen
lassen können
sie hatten bislang die situation einer
epidemie diesen ausmaßes in deutschland
noch nicht
um es klar zu sagen eine derartige
epidemie von der haben wir immer in
vorhersagen haben wir immer gesagt dass
so was mal geschehen kann ja jeder
wissenschaftler der sich mit
infektionsmedizin wird fasst beweis dass
die die schlimmste vorstellen die wir
haben eine pandemie ist mit einem virus
das über atemwegs über tröpfchen
übertragen wird und viele
lungenentzündung hervorrufen
das ist jetzt eingetreten das ist aber
eine andere situation als bei der grippe
unsere vorstellungen die höchste
wahrscheinlichkeit war immer das ist ein
grippevirus ist ein mutiertes
grippevirus ein verändertes das dazu
führt jetzt ist ein corona virus aber
die auswirken sind dieselben nur wie
gesagt dieses virus ist besonders
man hat besonders krankmachende
eigenschaften
danke vielen dank so das heißt nur damen
und herren solange wir keinen impfstoff
haben müssen wir abstand voneinander
halten und müssen uns zu hause aufhalten
wenn es irgendwie geht ansonsten droht
ja es droht eine ausgangssperre
zuerst die bayerische kleinstadt
mitterteich bald das ganze land
ausgangssperre raus darf nur noch wer
einen triftigen grund hat arbeiten oder
einkaufen es sind nicht nur die rasant
steigenden infektionszahlen sondern auch
bilder wie diese jugendliche bei
sogenannten corona partys wie hier in
berlin die das abstandhalten ignorieren
weil das